Look at this wild
map of every public sauna in Finland.
This was made by a Reddit user,
and I have no way of fact checking it,
but one thing's for certain
is that Finns love their saunas.
Every government
building is required to have one.
And not just to relax–
to conduct diplomacy as well.
The Finnish president
and the head of the Soviet Union
saunaed together
and they came to some good agreements
that allowed Finland
to stay neutral in the Cold War.
Two sweaty, naked world leaders
negotiating Finland's
neutrality during the Cold War in a sauna.
I freaking love it.
Finland just joined NATO and guess what?
NATO is installing a sauna.
And here in Washington DC,
where I live,
the Finnish embassy has a sauna society
where they invite people
to come sauna with them
and talk about global affairs.
Am I making this video
because I secretly want to be invited
to the Finnish Sauna Society
here in Washington, D.C.?
Yes.
So, Finland,
if you are hearing this,
I accept your invite, if you'll have me.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.